يعني احنا بنطلع
للعالم الغربي والعالم وامريكا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وغيره بنطلع بيجوا على
اسرائيل هنا بدوها بالسلاح اللي بقتل
شعبنا وامتنا شعب الفلسطيني وبنطلع لهم
بعد فتره بروح على مصر ولا من الاردن ولا
من اي مكان بقولوا احنا بدنا نمد مساعدات
للشعب الفلسطيني يعني بدوا اليهود بالسلاح
اللي يقتلونا فيه وبدهم يجيبوا لنا
مساعدات لا احنا ما بدنا مساعدات ولا بدنا
اي حاجه من الدول الاوروبيه ولا من
الولايات المتحده ولا من الاعراب حتى احنا
بدنا كرامه احنا بدنا حريه احنا ما بدنا
حد يكون وصي علينا لا من امريكا احنا هي
الغزه واحنا المقر ايش بده يكون في بلدنا
واحنا بدنا حريه زي باقي شعوب العالم كلها
ليش احنا بدنا وصيه لا بدنا وصيه من
امريكا ولا مين يحكم غزه ولا مين كذا احنا
اصحاب الارض واحنا اصحاب الشان وهذه
حريتنا وبلدنا ومن حقنا احنا نقرر ما
بدناش حد يقرر
اننا
l